the Joe Rogan experience what's your
opinion I wanted to pick your brain on
that because I'm me my wife we have a
pact okay and people are gonna think
we're crazy but I don't give a [ __ ] we
have since we met in 2016 and in
Thailand we never had a night apart we
Wow I know I know no nights apart oh my
and I loved it because I said that I
don't know we have only one life and I
love her too that she's my life partner
she's my you know she always believed in
me I think she's the reason why I became
champion because prior to meeting her I
was just no ambition no not you know I
mean and then my point is is that the
reason behind that is that I wanna you
need more coffee yeah yeah I need to I
want to spend as much as I can because
you don't know if there's something
after so what do you think I think you
should be happy and if you're happy
doing that that's alright I'm you're not
for nothing about that I'm super happy
with that that's my goal in life is to
like to have as much as much time as I
can and with her but I mean do you think
because it's so far it's healthy no no
that this about the afterlife like I'm
like and then for first like science I
think a leads to that we're gonna just
cease existing yeah but that's not
science honestly okay
well science is the study of how the
brain works in the study of where you
know where the memory is located in what
parts of the brain are affected by
injury and Studies on fMRI where they're
measuring areas of the brain that are
active during specific activities that's
real science there's no real science
about what happens we don't I mean your
speculation I mean I could buy your
physical body I'm so we're gonna just
like that it's gonna die right and then
then my point is I know there's I've
seen no science about that but my point
is I'm doing speculations that if we do
stop existing we do stop living and
breathing what's our essence where is it
going or I was if is there's an energy
there's a spirit what like it's so hard
to it's so hard to say well no one can
really say it's pure speculation and I'm
always skeptical of people that think
they know for sure nothing happens as
much as I'm skeptical people that think
for sure they know balloons so it's just
comforting for some people to have an
answer whether it's the likes go out and
that's it I mean that's Richard Dawkins
perspective oh yeah is it yeah but other
people's properties had never done
psychedelics it's like he's got this
very reductionist perspective scientific
based on what we know he's adamant that
if you when you die you die yeah but
that's nonsense he doesn't know I mean
you don't know me I understand that he's
a man of science and logic and this is
how he likes to frame the world but the
reality is no one has any idea and most
people don't want to dear to that train
of thought because it's very scary well
it's also if you've done psychedelic
drugs you know that there's a very
strange thing that can happen to your
brain to your consciousness when it
interacts with certain molecules what is
that they're related well some people
believe that that is a portal to the
afterlife and that what happens when you
die in during periods of extreme stress
your brain produces psychedelic
chemicals we don't know what the what
the soul is what is that a real thing is
that not is it nonsense we don't know is
your consciousness your consciousness is
clearly affected by injury injury to the
brain and your it's clearly affected by
age it's clearly affected by
deterioration it's clearly affected by
some exogenous chemicals okay but is but
is that you or is that something that
your your brain is housing I mean what
happens when you die does that does it
transfer to something else do you does
your brain you know house consciousness
or does your body house consciousness or
is consciousness a part of it and when
your brain shuts off there's no activity
this is a consciousness cease or you do
transcend no one knows I really been
Penn and Teller
yes what's the big guys name Penn yeah I
like is what he said he said we don't
know that's the real answer the real
answers we don't know yeah anybody's
saying other thing that that is I mean I
don't know maybe they know something we
don't the hope but it's interesting it's
interesting to think of you know and
there's a lot of people that don't
believe that you are the same person
every day there's a lot of people that
believe that when you go to
sleep that you you wake up in the
morning and you assume that all of your
memories of your life they're accurate
and that you are absolutely the person
that you were when you went to bed the
day before but you don't even know that
oh Sh oh that's a great you don't know
that you know that you have some
memories that you you can call upon
unless you record them like you do but
even if you record them like who the
[ __ ] is recording it you sure that's you
okay I mean are you the same person and
be this there's all these ideas of many
worlds these quantum physicists like to
bring up that there's a bunch of
different interactions that are
happening simultaneously and that it's
so hard to even it's so hard even to
even conceive of the possibility of
multiple dimensions and then the the
possibility of infinite universes that
kind of conceived them that we travel
back and forth through all these
different things and that based on the
decisions that you make based on who the
[ __ ] knows although an infinite number
of variables that your life moves in a
bunch of different directions you know
the idea of an infinite universe also
means there's an infinite number of
David ladoos out there I know that's
what's really crazy there's an infinite
number of young Jaime's there's an
infinite number of you know fill in the
blank neil degrasse tyson's Mike Tyson
the van der Holyfield is an infinite
number of them and they're all doing
different things it's all slightly
different lives how was it when you did
that when you did the DMT I've done a
bunch of times
it's very strange I'm scared of that you
should be scared okay I'm scared and
what does it look like what does it look
like it looks like well it depends on
the purity of it when you get it really
pure it's almost like a white looking
crystal sometimes it's a little bit
yellowish it's a lot more of a yellowish
looking crystal it's yeah and you
freebase it that's something that our
brain creates yes your brain produces it
that's one of the reasons why your body
can bring it back to baseline so quickly
your body knows what to do with it it
has it it's it's a part of your your
whole you know
chemical system how'd you come out let
how did you read about this how did you
come up with this I don't remember how I
first heard of it I think I heard of it
listening to Terence Mckenna talk about
it I think that was the first thing I
ever heard of it and when you know when
I first did it I couldn't even believe I
couldn't believe that this is a
possibility that this that this is
something that exists on earth that so
many people don't even know about
did you like you need to lock the doors
when you do it like you need to mean I
did it in a you know I did it in my
living room with some friends about 15
points short it's very there's like a
three-day thing I'm gonna no no good
feels like three days okay it feels like
forever and then instant it feels like
it just happened and it also feels like
forever but it's it's very strange it
feels like you've been there before when
you go there there's one yeah it's like
you leave the world you leave this space
and you go to some incredible dimension
that seems more real than this it's very
very dense
[Applause]